the presidency recognizes that all
elements inside and outside vinegary mff
will have to be adjusted downwards in
order to contribute we needed reduction
of the overall amount the weighting of
reductions among different headings
should though be based on certain
principles the presidency believes that
this is the time that we should all aim
for a compromise and move from our
original positions in order to reach and
deal in November we welcome the fact
that that negotiating box doesn't
contain any precise figures yet because
we see that it's still too early in the
process but we nevertheless object to
the inclusion of the language and
particularly the statements that it is
inevitable that the total level of
expenditure proposed by the commission
will have to be adjusted downwards the
Commission doesn't accept this premise
and will continue to defend both the
overall level of the mff that is
proposed as necessary and to the
allocations to the individual headaches
we share the president's view that we
need to find sufficient savings in all
areas of expenditure so we have to look
at it across the board when it comes to
the negotiating boxes we agree with the
presidency that cuts are necessary in
all headings as I said and I'm pleased
to see this principle reflected in the
box we cannot spend more but we surely
can spend it better EU budget represents
a substantial sum of money and we have
to make sure that it contributes
efficiently and effectively to growth
competitiveness and jobs luring the
already problematic capping rate in
cohesion policy is not acceptable it
doesn't it doesn't make sense if you if
you take into account the overall
objective of the obvious cohesion policy
meaning the convergence hey national
adjustments you know people say that
they have to correspond with european /
budget adjustments and i think that's
not correct now we have to look at the
multiplier effect of the community
budget and we have to be consist
at the last council European Council we
adopted the growth agenda we're in favor
of a growth agenda and then we're going
to cut contributions to the budget it's
not consistent it doesn't make sense and
it's politically very difficult to
defend the new mff therefore should not
punish a member state which is clearly
delivering in deficit and debt reduction
it would not be possible to explain to
the Hungarian people why a minus thirty
percent of cohesion allocation takes
place after all the sacrifices so it
would be conceived as a clear punishment
by the Hungarians why choose the
cohesion funds for cuts when cohesion
funds are created to maintain solidarity
particularly in infrastructure projects
within do let's not say amongst the poor
states but amongst the developing member
states and my second question is why
propose a downward trend in cohesion
fans when as an eco has just said a
majority at least an American majority
are against it is this wise is it wise
to do so if one wants to reach a
consensus we consider that reducing the
total level of expenditure has no solid
grounds in a time when public investment
must be increased a view shared by the
majority of the Member States the
European Commission and the European
Parliament we continue to support the
overall amounts proposed by the European
Commission I welcome the conclusions
that the overall expenditure level will
have to be reduced by comparison to the
Commission proposal and the Commission
proposal would lead to a twenty-five
percent increase of our contribution
this is unacceptable for us therefore
for Austria and adequate correction is
necessary on cohesion policy we welcome
in particular the Polish month of the
paragraph concerning the reserve safety
net
since this introduction would lead to a
significant unjustified reduction of
funds for the least developed member
states if applied this double capping
who have very little and a significant
contribution to do to the reduction of
the EU budget as a whole but at the same
time would affect very seriously the
convergence process mainly in the
Buddhist member states we all have
agreed that Europe desperately needs
investment for growth they currently
proposed amendments in negotiation
negotiating box create and justified
cuts in cohesion policy allocation for
some of the most fiscally prudent
countries including my own young what a
favor a better spending we certainly
recognize their own itude in that
principle but as spending doesn't lessen
in better spending less you can I spend
little and spend badly no better
spending is spending more efficiently
let me remind you but European
expenditure should serve to promote
growth and job so as we see it it's not
that obvious that the Commission
proposal should be reduced we need to
understand exactly where we can be more
efficient and where we can make the
necessary savings if need be in inverse
of croutons badal in allen lubricant
which deters abnormal again authorities
are we welcome the reference to need to
make cuts in all headings i'd like to
make it clear again all headings should
make their contribution to the necessary
cut so which we feel have to be made
visibly the Commission proposal on the
main point more substance on better
spending we need more substance in the
indication box on our better spending
member states need to see where some of
their funds are being used for key
project so which are particularly good
for promoting growth and jobs we would
look favorably we welcome the realism
of the presidency in saying that the
Commission's figures need to be adjusted
downwards and they need to be spread
across fairly across the various
headings which means it will not be the
same across the board as is proposed by
the commission so like Germany I would
look at the adjustment of the direct
payments if you look at article 52 that
is not acceptable it's not acceptable
that the see AV should be the adjustable
element within the negotiations our
feeling is that they figure proposed by
the commission is about right my
minister said this publicly on Friday
Belgium has made 13 billion euros cut in
its own budget over the last two months
but we do think we should make a bit of
an effort for the European budget better
spending is not just various mechanisms
which we might have in debt or the other
policy but also how are we going to
structure the budget how are we going to
change or not change and that would be
our wish throw investment nature of the
EU budget and you will never convince
them that having class for investments
in the you budget is better spending it
will be worse spending they think by
limiting the ambitions of the EU
policies from the next seven years we
don't serve our purpose but I think the
biggest and strongest political i will
say aberration is that the major cuts
are done in in the cohesion policy in
the middle of a crisis in the middle of
increase unemployment disparities
instead of convergence which is one of
the main objectives of the european
union so i think this is politically not
dependable ending doesn't imply spanning
less or to put it another way the
quality aspect doesn't need to be
confronted with the quantity aspect of
it
as far as the Portuguese position is
concerned I can tell you we cannot agree
with cuts which above all affect
cohesion and agriculture these are areas
where the Commission proposal was
already very under ambitious and we
certainly cannot agree at all with cuts
in all headings except heading 1 a which
is well the proposal is for a real
growth we agree with the president say
that the overall volume of the EU budget
should be reduced the Czech Republic is
convinced that mff volume of maximum 1
percent of EG and I in commitments can
ensure an adequate financing on a few
priorities while respecting fiscal
consolidation efforts of the Member
States I think all of us do actually
want to reach an agreement in November
but I believe the only way this is going
to be achievable is if we are working
with numbers that amount to at most a
real-terms freeze that is a generous
offer and anything else I think is going
to be X unacceptable in the domestic
climate of cuts and savings not just in
the UK but in many other member states
as well we feel at the level of
expenditure of being proposed by the
commission is appropriate to at the same
time I we realize that reality of course
is going to crush us andreas in the
direction that you've been saying with
the you negotiating box in gracious you
cohesion policy strong cohesion policy
is more than important tool for
facilitating and boosting growth and
jobs and should therefore not be subject
to further decrease in funding while of
course ensuring the better quality of
spending I share the conclusion of the
presidency that the total level of
expenditure proposed by the commission
will have to be adjusted downwards and
that is substantially in the final deal
we're a great lack of modernisation and
we have to prioritize growth
competitiveness and European added value
if European Union should keep pace with
Asia and United State
because it is a fact that reducing speed
to get to today compared with other
parts of the world it is necessary to
ensure that the future EU budget
reflects the consolidation efforts being
made by member states this is the first
condition first to be able to
re-establish growth unemployment
therefore commitment appropriation
should be reduced significantly compared
to the Commission's proposal Ireland
does not agree that the total level of
expenditure will have to be adjusted
downwards I think we have to consider
what the budget is for we need a
properly funded properly function
functioning european union with the
right mix of policies right mix of
priorities fair allocation of resources
and a focus on jobs and growth